from your heart spider i love that
hearts fire
these actors are not only powerful
avengers behind the camera but they also
are incredible voice actors in between
filming you do not want to challenge me
we are going to be sharing all the
off-screen secrets that transform these
brilliant performers into the animated
characters they portray trust me it's
ruled by an alien queen and she'll try
to brainwash your friends
number one
chris evans definitely had a blast no
pun intended being the voice of buzz
lightyear
finally look how good this looks my god
though in the beginning he was super
nervous in the booth the first couple
sessions in the booth were a little
intimidating he couldn't stop over
analyzing the sound of his own voice and
described himself feeling like a deer in
headlights there seems to be no sign of
intelligent life anywhere who are you
talking to no one eventually though he
did loosen up and was able to really
lean into the physical aspect of his
performance to infinity
and beyond
number two
taika waititi is a brilliant performer
so brilliant in fact he doesn't even
need to know what's going on in the film
as he's performing i've seen it and i
still don't know what's going on
apparently the story of lightyear
developed as it went the actors
performed different versions of the film
and the final result was what the
creators just naturally landed on
ready
ready no way not really it seems like
taiko ytt's go with the flow attitude
was pretty appropriate well this is
pretty cool number three here comes
elena florence p was very experienced
when it comes to being on screen but
when it comes to voice over well it's a
whole new world of possibilities you're
supposed to be dead
pew's very first time being cast in an
animated film was for the epic puss in
boots 2. you've never seen a goldilocks
quite like this before i loved having an
honest connection with her
number 4.
not only does paul rudd make an
appearance in bob's burger's sixth
season as jericho tina's talking horse
hey who needs real horses anyway can a
real horse do this
but we get to see him again in the bob's
burgers movie paul rudd is a seasoned
voice actor and brings a whole new level
of comedy to the classic animated series
i'm on this show this is this is who i
play number five seriously though what
can't scarlett johansson do among all of
the incredible films she's been in she's
also starred in several animated ones
spongebob wherever you are you better
hurry she delivers an outstanding
performance in wes anderson's
stop-motion film isle of dogs
i thought you knew all about me
number six
jeremy renner worked super hard on the
set of arctic dogs but he still managed
to have a great time doing it i worked
really hard for this
he turned something so practical like
doing several takes for one line of
dialogue into a lesson on honing his
skills it's really fun and challenging
just to hone in on the lines and the
delivery of the lines not only did he
play the film's protagonist swifty but
he also worked on the production's music
i think that's pretty awesome
number seven
zoe saldana does a complete 180 from her
character gamora to her character maria
in the book of life did you think it was
going to be that easy
she loved being part of a film that not
only caters to the younger audience but
to the parents as well she was also
super excited to work with guillermo del
toro he's a filmmaker that i have loved
and respected a great deal
number eight
from the best superhero poses to the
booth there's no stopping scarlett
johansson the actress brought to life
ash the porcupine in both sing and its
sequel
uh
you guys okay
and this project was special for a few
reasons the first was a pretty exciting
fact for her daughter this is probably
one of the only films i can i can
actually show my daughter not only was
she the coolest mom in her child's
friend group after that she also got to
work with one of her childhood heroes
the one and only bono
the only downside of working with the
music legend was the fact that she had
to keep it a secret from everyone in her
life for so long the sing franchise has
been pretty stellar for the black widow
actress no wonder she was always having
fun in the booth yeah it's it's just
wonderful um very very special number
nine
tom holland is an incredible actor and
performer but there are some things he
struggles with when portraying his
characters particularly laughing
well that's not good he has a really
hard time laughing on cue in order to
get around this they recorded audio of
him laughing in no relation to his lines
and just used that every time his
character walter had to laugh when
shooting the transformation scene with
will smith tom was really intimidated
after hearing will's audio for the first
time i have to do all these like crazy
different voices and i was actually
really embarrassed when we were
recording that scene number 10
karen gillan who portrays nebula in the
avengers gets to play a totally
different and much more wholesome
character in spies and disguise eyes
they call me eyes spectral analysis and
quantum optical thermography one notable
difference for her when voicing an
animated character versus acting on
screen was that she had to channel every
emotion she was trying to convey through
her voice alone it was a really cool
experience actually it felt like i could
really just let loose and really go for
it and have a lot of fun number 11. he's
not just quick the pietro actor might be
a speed demon in the mcu but throw him
in a voice over booth and the actor can
pull out all the stops any family guy
fans may have recognized the voice of
jaden to be none other than taylor
johnson himself in the chap stewie
episode in season 21. father is it going
to live here for a while the actor may
not hang out in the voice booth very
often but when he does it's a real treat
who knew his upper crest vibe was so on
point there's a new whole world to me
number 12
as we all know pixar definitely has a
way of pulling at our heartstrings chris
pratt made a comment on twitter about
grown men crying while watching onward
he was no different no i have three
remember his beard was scratchy had a
goofy laugh and he used to play drums on
his feet he had a very emotional
experience starting from the original
pitch i cried hearing the pitch to this
movie it's very emotional it's very
moving
number 13.
tom holland loved working on onward with
his buddy chris it was definitely one of
the highlights of making the film for
him tapping into any brain just let me
go they have great chemistry and had a
lot of fun portraying the voices of
these two brothers this is for a game
based on real life in real life tom is
the oldest sibling and chris is the
youngest but in the film they get to
switch
tom loved this aspect because he always
wanted an older brother and chris is
like that for him in a lot of ways as a
friend and fellow actor i basically just
played my younger brother paddy is kind
of how i approach this role number 14.
something really cool about robert
downey jr's role on family guy is that
it wouldn't have happened if he wasn't
such a big fan of the show he called up
the show's production staff and asked if
he could assist or produce one of the
episodes this led to the creation of the
infamous family guy episode the fat guy
strangler he's feeding he killed twice
and he's gonna do it again number 15.
the undeniably talented don cheadle gets
to portray one of his most challenging
characters yet
donald duck when you're trying to be any
duck but when you're trying to be donald
duck
you cannot mess around he really tried
to get into the psyche of donald duck
he often pondered what makes a duck tick
questions we would all love the answers
to
the talent of these actors truly never
ends does it did any of these castings
surprise you which mcu actor do you want
to see dive into the world of voice over
next